good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I only
have one picture of myself from the age
of 23 this is the only photographic
evidence I have of the year I spent in
Chicago in an intense and loving but
doomed relationship the year I started
and restarted the book that became
Looking for Alaska and also the year
when to borrow a line from Emily
Dickinson a plank in reason broke and I
dropped down and down you know what I'm
assigning feelings to that picture that
aren't really in it because I was quite
happy when that photograph was taken but
anyway I was thinking about it recently
because for the past decade or so my
life has been you know significantly
better photographed like I have hundreds
of pictures of myself at 39 and between
Sarah and me we've taken over a thousand
pictures of our kids this year which is
great but I feel like we citizens of the
internet are in general better at
creating stuff than we are at preserving
curating and archiving it so I wonder
how many of our pictures will still be
around in 15 years like it's often
posited that when archeologists of the
distant future look at our period of
human history they'll be like abundance
increased dramatically in the 19th and
20th centuries and then people started
building fewer amazing churches and
instead they began to worship screens
and since they'll have no idea what was
inside of those screens and the data
will be corroded the people of the
future will know about Wikipedia only
because of like the printed books that
mentioned it which is an interesting
idea but I have a couple problems with
it first it assumes that in the distant
future there will be people secondly it
ignores the many archivists who are
working very hard to ensure that some
slice of digital life is preserved for
future historians in fact that's why I
started thinking about this in the first
place an academic library recently got
in touch with us about preserving some
stuff from Brotherhood 2.0 in
nerdfighteria now of course it would be
nice to have more than one picture of
myself from when I was 23 but we don't
want to archive everything forever right
I mean for one thing there is no forever
but also like I'm grateful that I have
one picture of my great-grandmother I'm
not sure I'd need 17,000 of them also if
we start to feel like life isn't really
real and less or until it's photographed
we risk undervaluing all the really
important parts of life that aren't very
photogenic
you know like grief but just to be clear
I am NOT one of those old people who
thinks it's bad news that young people
are taking so many pictures these days
photographs aren't just a way of
remembering they're a way of having a
conversation with yourself and others my
concern is only
in constantly creating new things we
risk forgetting about the old things
that might someday be useful to us like
there were once more photos of me at 23
for instance there were someone
Friendster a now-defunct social
networking site but those pictures died
with Friendster now Facebook and
Instagram will likely be around for
decades if not centuries and lots of us
are backing up our poems and artwork and
photographs to the cloud but when I go
to the Internet Archive and go back even
a few years to see what nerdfighteria
used to look like there are already
holes I can see what the blog brother's
channel looked like at the end of 2007
that we've made 237 videos and had nine
thousand subscribers where I can see
what the page looked like in July of
2009 when we had 90,000 subscribers but
a lot is already gone the comment that
started the evil baby orphanage is gone
lots of the early nerdfighter artwork is
gone sites are shuttered links are dead
now I don't want nerdfighteria to be a
backwards-facing community and I don't
labor under the delusion that our little
corner of the internet will be
significant to scholars but it's
significant to me and since that library
emailed I've been thinking about what to
archive and how to archive it and so I
thought I would ask you whether you've
been around for a long time or you're
new in town when you think of
vlogbrothers and nerdfighteria what do
you think of what if anything should be
archived and do you have copies of it
because I might not also a little piece
of advice if you're 23 or even if you're
not take a bunch of pictures of yourself
this year save them to the cloud but
then also maybe print some of them out
just in case the physical things end up
being the ones that last Hank I'll see
you on Friday